[Music]
the Carter yeah I'm coming to y'all
straight from Rikers penitentiary bitch
you heard me
haters out there think I'm playing some
kind of joke young man I'm up on his
hold prison here young man where you
going hey man where you going
[Applause]
I see pick on the little guy
[Music]
call me agent
Jaden Pinkett Smith my man Hey look man
I'm gonna be real with you okay
this alien boy script I'm not feeling it
I mean it's hard being Will Smith's son
I just want to make sure my next project
reflects I'm a down-to-earth normal kid
am I making any sense I've got a script
right here very real called street ball
talk to me Tony he's a kid from the
streets lives in the hood in a house
with his mom that house oh it's like a
tiny mansion got it go on so his mom and
he they live in this house and she works
at a supermarket so like where the
butler's go wait you said his mom was
doing something at the supermarket
working what working is kind of like
acting on a set everyday in a film that
no one's ever gonna see and it lasts for
the rest of your life oh like a maid
awesome continue so he decides to start
playing pickup games of street ball
outside so he plays basketball in his
plane on the ground in his limo outside
is that stuff that goes five when you're
inside the limo oh snap he plays
basketball outside the limo door yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball and then
blahblah blah blah blah fast-forward at
the heart of the story Tony has to
choose choose yeah choose is when you
have to make a decision between two
things you want but you can have only
one but there's two yeah but I mean he
can't have both what'd I say about
science fiction Clyde it's a no okay
we'll pass
- dad bless you thanks and now ladies
and gentlemen the man you've been
waiting for mr. Michael Winslow another
sold-out night for the kings of mouth
noise I tell you though we wouldn't have
this audience without Winslow lucky for
you huh there's Police Academy fans look
at all the t-shirts six seagulls every
sound effect this guy makes is like a
little tiny Mona Lisa popping out of his
mouth and you ever heard him do the walk
in through leaves in the fall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]